le minimum c'est 25 cm vous en avez
suffisamment aimeriez-vous mieux un
petit peu plus encore françoise est une
fière employée de 73 ans j'ai un
département de courtepointe qui me fait
du bonheur j'ai tellement de plaisir ici
je me suis fait plein d'amis on
rencontre des gens qui vivent la même
passion
son employeur Frédéric aime voir ses
employés plus âgés heureuse chez le
petit sucre la moitié de son personnel à
plus de 50/50 si tout le monde partait à
60 ans à la retraite
pour Frédéric mais aussi pour tous les
employeurs qui souffrent de la pénurie
de main d'oeuvre c'est dans ce contexte
que le gouvernement entame s'est
consultations sur son régime de rente
Québec entend aussi l'âge pour être
admissible à son régime de retraite l'un
des plus bas des pays de l'OCDE par
exemple aux États-Unis l'âge minimal est
de 62 ans en Allemagne de 63 ans au
Royaume-Uni de 66 ans il n'y a qu'en
France où la rente anticipée est
applicable à 60 ans pour les emplois
pénibles Québec faire passer l'âge
d'admissibilité de 60 à 62 ans peu
importe l'emploi juste en la reportage
de deux ans on a 22% de plus et ce 22 %
là on l'a pour toute la durée de nos
vies jusqu'à notre décès c'est une bonne
efficace du régime de rendre une
augmentation des prestations pour tous
les Québécois par exemple actuellement
une personne qui a droit à la rente
maximum reçoit 9600 dollars par année en
la demandant à 60 ans avec la réforme
qui repousse la rente à 62 ans elle
recevrait 2100 dollars de plus par année
les personnages gé entre 63 et 70 ans ne
verrai aucune différence dans leur
compte en banque le régime est en bonne
santé financière on n'a pas on n'a pas à
augmenter les taux de cotisation les
taux de cotations sont suffisants pour
payer les prestations pour au moins les
50 prochaines années pour ce chercheur
de l'Observatoire des retraites l'option
envisagée forcerait les Québécois moins
nantis à demeurer sur le marché du
travail il y a un corps des personnes
qui prennent leur retraite le font pour
des raisons de santé ou de handicap
travail depuis trois ans au plus petit
sucre elle fait partie des gens qui ont
demandé leur rente à 60 ans à 60 ans
j'étais vraiment là après burn-out je
voulais plus travailler je pouvais plus
elle ne voit pas d'un bon œil la
proposition de Québec 60 ans ça peut
être les physiques ça peut être le
mental la charge de travail la charge
mentale
sur le fun quand on pense qu'à 60 ans on
peut prendre notre retraite le 62 ça
peut être décevant pour bien des gens
sans compter que la bonification du
régime réduirait les prestations du
régime fédéral pour les moins nantis
l'actuaire du régime de rente du Québec
soutient que même avec une pénalité au
fédérale il est plus avantageux de
prendre la rente à 62 ans le supplément
de revenus garantis vient jamais
récupérer
l'augmentation de rentrée RQ au total ce
à quoi subjectes l'Observatoire des
retraites au final pour toute le temps
de leur retraite jusqu'à une espérance
de vie moyenne
par le vont avoir des revenus qui vont
être plus faibles que si il fallait
toucher aujourd'hui à l'âge de 60 ans
du gouvernement Françoise elle n'a pas
l'intention de rentrer chez elle je
pense pas d'arrêter encore tout de suite
en santé que je pourrais continuer avec
le même rythme et je vais continuer tant
qu'on vous demande ici et de ses
conseils précieux pour les courtes
pointes ici Marie José paquet como
Radio-Canada Montréal